A former top FBI
counterintelligence official
is under arrest here in New York
for allegedly trying to help
get a Russian oligarch off the s
list and also dig up dirt
on his political opponent.
Charles McGonigle is one of the
ranking former FBI officials
ever charged with a crime. He ha
not guilty.
Our Chris Canale
joins us now to talk about this.
One thing that I think
is also really interesting, Kyra
is that he used to supervise
investigations into Russian olig
then went to allegedly work for
and get paid
a lot of money by Oleg Deripaska
Yeah, I mean, that's
the crux of this charge right he
So this is the former top
official running the New York FB
office counter intelligence oper
preeminent position in the burea
Now, he is charged with violatin
laundering
and sanctions laws because of wo
he did once he left the bureau.
He started working for Oleg Deri
He is a sanctioned Russian oliga
because of his close ties
to Russian President Vladimir Pu
And what authorities say is
that you know, as you said, he w
he supervised investigations
into oligarchs, including into D
and then immediately went and st
working for him after he retired
They say that he was hired to di
on arrival of Deripaska
and that he hid this relationshi
by using a shell company
and forging signatures
to try to keep the path away fro
so no one could detect this.
But that wasn't just it.
He was also charged yesterday
by prosecutors in Washington, D.
with failing to disclose $225,00
he received from a former employ
of an Albanian intelligence agen
And that payment was while he wa
that top post at the bureau.
Now, while he was still doing th
he was still in charge of counte
He received this payment.
And he also, according to the in
failed to disclose trips
he took to Europe with this indi
who was an former intel
official in Albania,
and also failed to disclose meet
he had with the Albanian prime m
and other politicians overseas
that's all required when you wor
for the FBI, particularly in tha
with that type of clearance.
And he he's pleaded not guilty,
but he could be facing if convic
if convicted, of the most seriou
he could face a statutory maximu
20 years in prison.